Musik
Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Rock-Klassik-Radio, heute mit Florian Hinweil und Stefan Dietze zum Pufo. Freut mich, vielen Dank, dass ich da sein darf. Das war Hannes aus Hamburg mit seinem Erfolgshit Kill Kill Death Death Kill Death mit dem Chansonhit Kill Kill Death in C-Moll. Vielen, vielen Dank an Hannes für seine Einreichung, er kommt aus Hamburg. Liebe Grüße nach Hamburg, die Hafenstadt, die unser Herz erobert hat. Die Hafenstadt an der Elbe. Immer diese dusseligen Bei-Infos, die wir alle kennen, aber es hilft, um ein bisschen cleverer zu klingen. Es hilft einem zu verdeutlichen, dass jede Stadt an einem Fluss liegt, sodass wenn man irgendwann eine Fantasywelt baut, man daran denkt, dass jede Stadt Stadt einen Fluss braucht. Bre? Nicht so wie Anfänger, wie Bre hat kein Bächlein. Tolki, du Idiot. Du Trottel. Dummer Trottel. Wo ist der Fluss in Minas Tirith? Der liegt eher bei Osgiliath. Das glaube ich auch. Aber warum hat Minas Tirith keinen Fluss? Da kann man dann, hat man direkt, die Bundesrepublik hat gesagt, wir nennen jede unserer Städte Frankfurt am Main, Frankfurt am Rhein, Botswana am Rhein, damit wir die Möglichkeit haben, Leute darauf hinzuweisen. Finde ich gut. Finde ich auch gut, ja. Köln am Rinn, Kölle am Rinn, Kölle. Ne, finde ich gut. Macht ja auch Sinn. Ich glaube, als jemand, der aus einer Stadt kommt, wo die Autobahnen daneben wichtiger sind als die Flüsse, weil ich komme aus Kamen, das Kamener Kreuz ist sehr wichtig, grösste beiden Autobahnen kreuzen sich dort. Deswegen meine These, Strassen sind die neuen Flüsse. Meine These ist, jedes verdammte Kaff, egal wo man herkommt, hat irgendein Superlativ. Meine These ist, du bist ein scheiß Arschloch, du bist ein scheiß arrogantes Arschloch. Ach, Gegenthese, ich kenne mich ziemlich gut aus mit der Welt und ich glaube, du findest für jedes Kaff irgendeinen Superlativ. Wir haben irgendwie den intensivsten Muskatnussgeruch bei uns in der Fabrikgegend oder so. Nee, ist ja gar nicht mein Punkt. Nein, Wikipedia-Eintrag von jeder Stadt durch, ja, ich komme aus Ebersberg, uh, angrenzende Grösse Forstgebiet Europas, wow, toll, super. Und bei dir ist es das Kammerer Kreuz. Das ist mega cool, es ist mega cool, ich finde es alles cool. Ich kann mich für alle diese Punkte begeistern. Ja, aber jeder kann das sagen, jeder kann aus seiner Heimatstadt sagen, wir haben irgendwie den kleinsten Bürgermeister Deutschlands. So, das ist Rudolf Lipp und er ist 1,20. Lippli. Er wird auf Wahlkampfveranstaltungen gerne Lippi genannt. Ja, er ist so klein, dass man den auf den Wahlplakaten, musste man den so vergröchern,
dass er so pixellig wurde. Ja, oder dass du ihn ganz körperbildend auf dem Wahlplakat abbilden
kannst, dass du sagst, das ist ein
ganzer Mann für Lippstadt.
Kompetenz im Maßstab
eins zu eins, und dann ist er neben so eine
Originalgrösse von ihm.
Und ich weiß, er saß beim Wahlkampfmeeting
da und sagt, Leute,
lasst uns nicht klein, aber hochschreiben.
Lasst uns wirklich
nicht an den Punkt gehen. Die Wahlkampfmeeting da und sagt, Leute, lasst uns nicht Klein aber ho schreiben.
Lasst uns wirklich nicht an den Punkt gehen.
Die Wahlkampfmanagerin so, naja, aber es ist einfach, es kommt gut an.
Aber okay, ich hätte noch einen anderen Vorschlag.
Auf die Größe kommt es wirklich nicht an.
Britta.
Auf die Größe kommt es nicht an.
Britta, hör mir zu.
Ja.
Ich glaube, wir sollten einen Schritt weiter gehen.
Lippstadt braucht eine Politik, die 2022 angemessen ist.
Und diese alten Sprüche, Klein aber ho, in der Kürze liegt die Würze.
Ich glaube, da sind Sie auch als Marketingfirma Müller und Müller ein bisschen weiter. Müller und Müller und Müller. Gut, herzlichen Glückwunsch zur Einnahme Ihres letzten Konkurrenten. Das war der grosse Rivale. Somit sind Sie jetzt alleine in Lippstadt, die Monopolstellung gehört Ihnen. Sie sind auch die Besten. Britta, bitte verstehe mich nicht falsch. Oh, jetzt ist Ihnen der Stift runtergefallen. Oh, ich hebe Ihnen nur kurz auf. Dankeschön, kommen Sie ja nicht dran. Das ist sehr nett von Ihnen, danke. Ich glaube, wir müssen weitergehen für Lippstadt. Was haben Sie denn sonst noch? Auf die Größe kommt es nicht an. Genau, und dann? Klein aber hoch. Aber was Inhaltliches, also was irgendwie zu der Politik, ich will jetzt irgendwie, ich will den Spielplatz komplett renovieren, der braucht komplett neuen Sand, das ist eine riesige Aktion, das Spinnennetzklettergerüst. Noch eine andere Idee, für mich ist Lippstadt die grösste Stadt. In einer ganz kleinen Form, verhältnismäßig.
Okay, drücken Sie 10.000. Und so wurde Harry Lipp, Lippstadt, der kleinste Bürgermeister Deutschlands.
Jeder kann irgendeine tolle Geschichte aus seiner Heimatstadt erzählen.
Darum ging es mir gar nicht um dieses Kamlerkreuz-Namedropping, für das ja alle Kamler bekannt sind.
Mir ging es eher darum zu sagen, dass ich glaube, dass Strassen die neuen Flüsse sind. Überleg mal, was waren früher Flüsse. Geht aber ein bisschen näher drauf ein. Ja, hatte ich sogar vor. Was waren früher Flüsse? Überleg mal, was früher Flüsse waren. Da wurden Waren drauf transportiert. Du konntest dein Urin reinschmeissen. Man konnte zum Beispiel, kannst du auf die Straße, kannst du drauf pinkeln. Man kann Waren drauf transportieren, man trennt die Gebiete von Hamstern. Das alles können Straßen genauso gut, wie es Flüsse auch können. Und ich deswegen, weil man, ich beobachte gerade, wie Carmen wächst. Nicht unbedingt zum Schönen, sondern zu so einem Logistikstandort, mit so riesigen Hallen und Bertelsmannbauter und Woolworth und Toothbroth, die ganzen grossen… Haben wir die Lokalabteilung aufgemacht? Warum sind wir gerade in Kamener Regionalthemen drin eigentlich? Ich habe das Gefühl, ich muss jetzt mal hier ein bisschen Kommunalpolitik betreiben. Nee, deswegen ist es krass, wie um dieses Kamler Kamler Kreuz herum gerade so eine riesige Logistik entsteht. Und deswegen, so habe ich mir das vorgestellt, so sind früher Städte am Flussen gewachsen. Das ist, glaube ich, das Gleiche. Ja, kann sein, aber du sprichst es schon an, natürlich für Tiere ein großes Problem. Die meisten Tiere können durch Flüsse, aber nicht über Strassen. Und ich mag immer, ich habe so einen Bericht gesehen über so eine Brücke, die über so eine Strasse gebaut wurde mit Gras, damit die dummen Tiere denken, das ist Teil des Waldes, damit die über die Brücke gehen auf die andere Seite, damit die auf ihrem täglichen Arbeitsweg zur Arbeit über die Strasse gehen auf so einer Wildbrücke. Aber wenn Tiere zu dumm sind, zu checken, dass es ihre Wildbrücke ist, dann haben die es auch nicht mehr verdient. Aber ich mag die Vorstellung, dass einfach so ein Elch sagt, ah scheiße, ich muss auf die Nordseite jetzt, ich muss drüber. Ja, nimm die Brücke, ja dieser vier Kilometer südlich muss jetzt hin. Einfach so, du siehst den anderen Elch schon auf der anderen Seite der Strasse so, Udo, Udo, Udo, ich komm rüber. Kommst du rüber? Nee, komm du rüber. Ich komm rüber. Ja, komm rüber. Bis morgen. Bis morgen. Und dann läufst du in den ewigen Weg los. Generell, ich bin tatsächlich wieder ein Loch gefallen diese Woche, ein YouTube-Loch, und zwar Wildlifecams, Leute, die Zeit haben. Zeit ohne Kamera, mehr braucht man nicht, um ein YouTube-Video zu machen, das mehrere Millionen Klicks generiert. Und zwar, du stellst dir eine Kamera in den Wald mit Nachtsichtgerät und filmst, was passiert. Und du merkst, es passiert gar nichts. Also muss man das noch ein bisschen... Moment, sind die mit der Kamera im Wald oder ist die Kamera einfach im Wald? Die gehen in den Wald, hängen die Kamera an den Baum... Brauchst nicht so wühlen werden. Brauchst Aufregung nicht schlafen, denke ich. Ich könnte nicht schlafen. Ich könnte auch nicht schlafen. Wenn ich wüsste, im Wald hängt eine Kamera, die gerade alles filmt. Und dann stehen die viel zu früh auf am nächsten Morgen, weil sie nicht schlafen konnten, gehen in den Wald, nehmen die Kamera ab vom Baum, öffnen die Kamera, nehmen dort den Film raus, müssen ihn lange und mühsam entwickeln in der Dunkelkammer und können dann nach zwei Wochen endlich schauen, was passiert ist und es stellt sich aus, dass es gar nichts passiert ist. Es ist nichts. Nichts, gar nichts, kein Vogel, keine Amsel, kein Bär, kein Biber, gar nichts. Kein Eichelherr. Nichts und Und deswegen sagen sie, jetzt müssen wir ein bisschen nachhelfen. Und was jemand gemacht hat, hat er einfach fünf Kilo Erdnussbutter da hingelegt. Er war einen riesigen Haufen Erdbeid, er dachte, ich mag Erdnussbutter. Viele Leute lieben Erdnussbutter, Tiere lieben Erdnussbutter. Und einfach so einen riesigen Batzen, also wirklich so einen Gymnastikball, grossen Batzen. Neue These, Städte entstehen eher um Erdnussbutter-dichte Gebiete. Kann gut sein. Okay. Und dann hat er gefilmt, was passiert, und dann kamen da verschiedene Tiere und haben dann, vor allem das Interessante war, er hat dann erst Erdnussbutter kam tatsächlich gar nicht so gut an. Nur ein sohn Waschbär wollte das, aber ein normaler Bär wollte es nicht,
weil der hat dann noch so normale Erdnüsse drumherum getan und der Bär hat nur die Erdnüsse rausgenommen, aber nicht die Erdnussbutter.
Der mochte das einfach, dass du noch die Schale aufmachen musst.
Also er hat sich für Crunchy Peanut Butter entschieden.
Ja.
Und der Bär, da kam ein Bär hin, der die Stücke sich rausgefriebelt hat.
Nee, das waren tatsächlich ganze Erdnüsse.
Also er hat zwei Komponenten, einen Erdnussbutterhaufen und dann noch mal normale Erdnüsse aus der Tüte drüber. Wie, aber auch das ist super faul, weil er hätte noch viel mehr Komponenten hinlegen können. Hat er dann später auch. Und dann hat er nämlich hinzugefügt, was man als einziges... Aber der schläft doch dann nicht mehr. Dieser Kombination hinzu... Der schläft seit Wochen nicht. Wenn er jeden Tag diese Nervenaufreihen-Experimente macht, der kann doch nicht mehr schlafen. Der hat sich gesagt, was fehlt noch bei einem grossen Erdnussbutterhaufen? Natürlich Jelly. Ach so, ja. Peanut Butter Jelly. Und dann hat er wie so ein Vulkan so einen riesigen Marmeladenbatzen auch auf diesen Erdnussbutterbatzen hingebracht. Und da fand ich es interessant, weil da kamen dann manchmal Waschbären. Und manche Waschbären haben Erdnussbutter gegessen und andere Waschbären haben Jelly gegessen, haben die Marmalade gegessen. Ja, das ist die uncoolsten Tiere. Waschbären sind die uncoolsten Bären, schon mal auf jeden Fall. Hast du schon mal einen Koala-Bär gesehen? Coolster Bär? Nein, uncoolster Bär. Ja, stimmt. Okay, Top 60 der coolsten Bären. Platz Nummer 60 bei mir, der Ameisenbär, der kann weg. Come on, ey, der ist der coolste. Platz Nummer 60 ist für mich Waschbär, Boring, Lamo, man nennt ihn auch die Ratte der Bären, geht in Mülleimer und so rein, kein Geschmack. Der Bär der Lüfte vielleicht eher, oder? Bär der Lüfte, ja. Der Sperber, die Schlange der Lüfte. Okay, alles klar. Können wir nicht als Vogelnamen benutzen? Macht es komplizierter, diese Vereinfachung. Tauberatte der Lüfte, Blaumeise ist der Karpel der Lüfte. Stichwort Vereinfachung. Vielen Dank übrigens an unsere Reddit-Guys, die haben nämlich einen ganz tollen Kompass erstellt, wo man genau gucken kann, auf grad genau, wie es heißt, nach den neuen Kompassbezeichnungen, wo wir Osten und Westen abgeschafft haben. Ja, aber ich verwechsel Osten und Westen immer. Norden und Süden verwechsel ich nie. Niemals. In meinem Leben noch nie habe ich Norden und Süden verwechselt. Welcher Riesenidiot hat das schon mal verwechselt? Niemals. Ost-West verwechsel ich ständig. Deswegen einfach streichen. Und zwar wird Ost zu Nord-Süd und West zu Süd-Nord. Und dann gibt es noch viele Unterkategorien, die könnt ihr euch im Reddit anschauen. Reddit.com slash das Podcast. Wie machst du, stellst du sicher, dass du dich nicht verwechselst bei Osten ist Nord-Süd und weil du ja Norden und Süden kennst. Und dann musst du einfach, es ist eigentlich logisch, du fängst bei Norden an, also kommt das nächste Nord, Süd, Süd, Süd, Nord. Es ist wirklich, es gibt Sinn, weil du im Urzeigersinn bleibst. Das ist genau richtig. Das ist großartig. Ich wollte nur abschliessen, ich fand es nur interessant, dass selbst Waschbären dieselbe Tierart es manche gab, die die Marmelade lieber gegessen haben und manche gab, die lieber die Erdnussbüter gegessen haben.
Wo ich dachte, eigentlich jedes Tier hat eine klare Prioritätenliste, aber selbst da gibt es anscheinend persönliche Vorlieben.
Den Geschmack verstehe ich generell auch nicht.
Also, vielleicht liegt es an deren jeweiligem Upbringing, dass die einen, also klar, sagt man ja, dass auch DNA und so für Geschmack verantwortlich ist, aber ja auch so Umwelteinflüsse und sowas. Das heißt, vielleicht kamen die aus verschiedenen ... Kannst du da noch ein bisschen näher drauf eingehen? Ich will gerade ein bisschen weiter weg, ich will gerade eher das Größere. Also weil jetzt ... Es gibt noch ein, zwei Sätze, dann bin ich zufrieden. Jetzt ist die Frage, aus welchen Gebieten, der eine ist vielleicht eher aus Fichtennähe gross geworden, der andere eher bei Laubbaum. So und jetzt dann die verschiedenen Gerüche, mit denen die eh die ganze Zeit komfortiert sind, sorgen vielleicht dafür, dass die andere Vorlieben haben. Ja, finde ich total spannend. Ich finde es gar nicht spannend, ich finde es sehr langweilig. Man muss sagen, diese Woche war so ein bisschen die Woche, in der meine Träume zerstampft wurden, von allen Richtungen. Von allen Richtungen kamen dick besolte Schuhe auf mich ein und haben alles zerstampft. Unter anderem habe ich ja erzählt, wie ich als Kind verschiedene Apfelbäume im Garten hatte und getestet habe, schmecken Äpfel von unterschiedlichen Äpfelbaumen anders. Anders. Du merkst, ich bin emotional aufgewühlt. Und ich habe überlegt, und irgendwann habe ich mir eingeredet, ich kann herausfinden, welcher Apfel ist, von welchem Apfelbaum, weil ich dachte, ich hätte die charakteristisch erfasst. Hast du denn die Bäume anders behandelt? Natürlich, jeder hat einen Favoritenbaum. Die alle sagen, ich liebe alle Bäume gleich, aber wir wissen alle, dass jeder in seinem Garten einen Favoritenbaum hat. Auch so die Winzer, die haben auch natürlich ihre Lieblingsreben. Jeder, der Pflanzen im Haus hat, ich habe keine Pflanzen, aber jeder, der Pflanzen im Haus hat, sagt, die Hälfte der Pflanzen muss weg. Welche Hälfte? Könnt ihr sofort nennen, die raus, die raus. Das ist überhaupt kein Problem. Wenn es darauf anfängt. Arrogant, nervig, beurteilungsbedürftig. Ich hätte, aber dann eher, angenommen einen Baum pinkelt man an die ganze Zeit, den anderen Baum gibt man die ganze Zeit nur Fidji-Wasser und dem anderen Baum gibt man nichts, nur Regenwasser zum Beispiel. Dann würde ich mal gerne wissen, ob das in den Geschmack mit einfließt. Ich habe ja die These aufgestellt, Bäume sind Brüder, aber ein netter Biologe hat mich angeschrieben und meinte, nein, das sind identische Klone. Ach, und das, ja, vielleicht trennt das die von den Lebewesen, also sorry, von den, sorry, von den, von den richtigen Lebewesen, also, das kannst du da nicht sagen. Ja, sorry, aber ich sehe es nicht. Bäume sind doch genauso Lebewesen wie ein Huhn. Oder? Weiß ich. Also anscheinend nicht, wenn es identische Klone sind voneinander. Ja, also meine gesamte Jugend war eine Lüge. Die waren exakt identisch, aber auch er meinte, ja, vielleicht gibt es ja sowas wie Umwelteinflüsse auf dem Baum. So nämlich. Ja, kann sein natürlich, dass wenn der eine das Auto ständig davor parkt, dass der eine krank wird und hustet und weniger gute Äpfel macht als der andere, der den ganzen Tag in der Sonne steht, wer weiß. Alles interessant. Sind Pflanzen immer, die so nebeneinander sind, identische Klone? Kann gut sein. Aber gibt es nicht eine Befruchtung mit Biene und Baum? Aber die Biene bringt keine DNA mit ins Spiel. Ne, da bin ich jetzt komplett falsch gewickelt. Du bist kurz abgewogen. Da bin ich jetzt kurz falsch gewickelt. Du meinst, dass die Biene, Biene und Baum sind die Eltern eines neuen Baumes. Nein, der Baum alleine ist Eltern, ist alleine erziehender Baum. Das heißt, es gibt wirklich keine Befruchtung wie bei Menschen, dass zwei Genpools sich zusammentun, sondern immer der Baum, Baum, Baum, Baum, Baum. Ich check's überhaupt nicht, weil im Sommer Pollenflug, erklär mir Pollenflug, wie ich das sage. Kann ich dir nicht erklären. Nee, weil fliegen dann Pollen irgendwo hin, bestäuben da einen anderen Baum, der möglicherweise nicht Bruder oder Schwester, sondern einfach der Baum nochmal ist? Nee. Das heißt, der Stammbaum eines Baums ist kein Baum, sondern eine Linie. Aber wenn jetzt der Baum der gleiche Baum ist und die einen Sporen, Pollen, bestäuben den anderen Baum, dann kann er sich doch auch selber bestäuben direkt. Warum macht er es euch dann so schwer? Weißt du, er ist ja eher selbst. Er macht schon mehr Spaß, oder? Er besorgt sich sehr selbst. Da kann man es nicht selber machen, aber es ist schon interessanter, wenn noch irgendwo ein Baum, den man vielleicht nie gesehen hat. Um die Ecke, der immer nur die Pollen rüber und man denkt sich, eines Tages sehe ich diesen Baum. Aber angenommen, du hast einen identischen Klon. mit dem sex und ihr holt und ihr holt euch gegenseitig ihr holt euch gegen und ihr holt euch gegenseitig einen runter fühlt sich an wie selbstbefriedigung das ist meine frage das ist eine schwierige frage kommen wir zur nachricht von henning der alle unsere fragen rund ums thema blut beantwortet hat weil letzte folge blutlehr ste Stefan hatte kein Blut. Ich hoffe, es ist wieder da. Ich weiß es nicht. Wie geht das? Wie wird Blut erzeugt? So, und da haben wir nämlich ein paar Fragen. Ihr schreibt hier, pass auf, Leichen werden blass, weil das Blut sich dann verfestigt und weil der Sauerstoff schnell verbraucht ist, der für die hellrote Farbe sorgt. Also Leichen haben nicht einfach weniger Blut und sind deswegen blass, sondern der Sauerstoff fehlt. Ihr habt richtig festgestellt. Oh, I like this beginning. Nochmal, ihr habt richtig festgestellt. Warte, jetzt habe ich mich kurz verrutscht. Ich muss nochmal anfangen. Ihr habt richtig festgestellt, Doppelpunkt, das Blut ist nicht immer gleich verteilt. Wenn Florentin als Hummer aus der Badewanne steigt, dann wird das Blut verstärkt in die hautnahen Gebiete geleitet, um den Körper abzukühlen. Dafür wird es abgezogen, wo es ... Weil es zu kalt ist, oder was? Nee, weil es zu heiß ist. Ich habe ein heißes Bad. Aber das schafft der Körper ja nicht, oder, das abzukühlen. Das ist ja vergebene Liebesmühe eigentlich. Ich meine, ich liege in einer heißen Badewanne mit heißem Wasser. Trottel. Dafür wird es abgezogen, wo es vermeintlich aktuell nicht so dringend benötigt wird. Herz. Und das ist die Frage, wo kommt das Blut immer her? Was sind diese Blutreservoirs, die sozusagen die Reserve liefern? Oft handelt es sich um das Verdauungssystem. Dadurch, dass dann das fixe Blutvolumen aber oft über mehr Körperbereiche verteilt wird, sinkt oft der Blutdruck, was dazu führt, dass Hummerflorentin beim Verlassen der Badewanne schneller schwindelig wird, da weniger Blut im Körper ankommt. Auch deshalb sollte man nicht kurz vor dem Schwimmen viel essen, man verwirrt den Körper, indem man ihm sagt, Bauch und Muskeln brauchen gleichzeitig viel Blut.
Gesteuert wird der Mechanismus über Muskeln, in den Arterien und in kleinen Arteriolen.
Bis dahin fand ich es sympathisch, jetzt ein bisschen übertrieben mit dem Fachbegriff.
Aber in der Fall habe ich jetzt so wieder nicht verstanden, warum wir nicht schwimmen gehen.
Sag mal konkret, weil immer alle waren, einen davor, nach dem Essen schwimmen zu gehen.
Niemand hat konkret mal gesagt, was da passiert.
Hat mal eine tapfere Seele sich gesagt, nee, ich mache jetzt einfach einen grossen Sauerbratentag mit Schupfnudeln. Ich mache einen Sauerbratenschwimmtag. Ja, und mache dann Hecht. Ich glaube, was er schreibt, ist, eigentlich ist Schwimmen auswechselbar mit jeder Art von Sport, dass wenn du gleichzeitig isst, der Körper denkt, ah, jetzt wird verdaut, du dann anfängst zu rennen, der Körper sein Blut aus dem Verdauungstrakt wieder abzieht und ich weiss wohin damit und dann hast du Kreislaufschwiegen. Aber warum ist beim Schwimmen so ein Mysterium, so ein, was passiert da ein Mysterium, wenn niemand wieder auf die Idee kommen, genau was ist, das ist ja so dieses Kind fast nicht auf die heiße Herdplatte mässig. Weil niemand will, dass du ins Becken kotzt. Die Erektion des Penis funktioniert ganz ähnlich. Wird er gebraucht oder will er gebraucht werden, dann öffnen sich die Penisarterien in den Schwellkörpern weiter, sodass viel mehr Blut einströmt, als abfließen kann. Dieses Prinzip wird bei Medikamenten wie Viagra gezielt ausgenutzt. Fun Fact, Viagra war ursprünglich als Medikament gegen Lungenhochdruck in Erforschung. Nach Beendigung der Studie wollten auffällig viele männliche Probanden das Medikament, aber unbedingt weiter verschrieben bekommen. Viele Grüße, Facharzt für Innere Medizin, Henning, vielen Dank, dass du uns geschrieben hast. Jetzt wissen wir alles über Blut, vielleicht bist du ein Vampir. Ich würde es nochmal gesagt haben, damit wir, wenn das rauskommt, nicht als Vampirfreunde dastehen, wir haben die Behörden schnellstmöglich informiert. Dankeschön. Ich habe immer noch nicht verstanden, ob Adern sich dem Blut ... Und auch da muss ich sagen, Herr Henning ... In den Adern gibt es anscheinend Muskeln, die das aufziehen oder zudrücken. Das habe ich jetzt mal so abgeleitet. Das heißt, die Arterien sind biegbar, so schlauchig, und die auf und zu gemacht. Weil da ist ja immer Blut drin.
Aber müsste jetzt ein wirklich ambitionierter Bodybuilder jetzt auch sagen, ich will auch diese Muskeln stärken. Also ich will immer schnell hin und her, Verdauung Muskel, Verdauung Muskel, damit diese Muskeln stark werden. Ich weiss nur, dass berühmte Profelle Bodybuilder an Vor-Wettkampftagen nichts trinken, damit sie dann, wenn sie dann auf die Bühne gehen, damit die Adern poppen, damit die Adern und die Venen richtig rauskommen. Das finde ich ja immer. Nee, aber das gilt als Schönheitsideal. Ja, ich weiß, das ist in Ordnung, aber das ist, glaube ich, der Punkt, der mich am meisten vom Workout, vom Gym abhält, ist diese Adern, die da so rausstehen. Was? Ich finde das einfach unangenehm, ich finde, das sieht nicht gut aus. Mein persönlicher Geschmack, ich verstehe, dass das zu einem Körperbild gehört, aber ich will das nicht und deswegen bin ich auch lange nicht mehr im Gym gewesen. Weil du Angst hast, dass die Adern rauskommen können? Ja, mir gefällt das nicht irgendwie. Ich will das, ich weiß auch nicht, wo die jetzt sind. Also sind die jetzt irgendwo in den Macherkoding drin? Warum in Frage stellen? Aber ich finde es so gut, dass sie sich so angreifbar machen. Ich habe das Gefühl, dass es so, je besser sich der Körper verteidigen kann, desto mehr kommen die Adern so aus ihren Verstecken und sagen dann irgendwann, irgendwann liegen sie so brach in der Sonne so, komm doch. Ja, das ist so das Schwachstellenprinzip. Aus Videospielen kennt man es, auch ein grosser Boss hat immer eine Schwachstelle. Ich glaube, so funktioniert der Körper auch, dass wenn du so richtig krasser Bodybuilder bist und eigentlich unbesiegbar, sagen die, nee, komm, fahr die Adern raus, fahr die Adern raus, damit da jemand kann. So sind wir OP. Aber ich finde das so ekelhaft. Kurze Frage, kann man die denn verschieben, die Adern? Wenn ich jetzt die Ader so wirklich definiert auf meinem Oberarm habe, kann ich die dann einfach verschieben oder ist die da fix? Weil die sind ja teilweise länger als die Strecke, die sie überwinden, die sind ja so gewunden. Sind die denn da festgetackert? Ach Gott. Ach, die sindgetackert, ja, ja. Die sind da jetzt nicht so lose. Nichts ist lose. Es hat schon alles irgendwie. Es funktioniert alles. Ja, du, das bezweifle ich auch gar nicht, aber es ... Sorry, ich glaube, Medizinstudium ist 50 ... 50 % englisch und 50% Deutsch.
Ja, das stimmt.
Die eine Hälfte einfach nur den ganzen Tag, was, und die andere Hälfte nur, ne, ne.
Ist das schon mal passiert, dass im Medizinstrum jemand rausgegangen ist und so, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, das werde ich nicht machen, damit werde ich, ich bin Zahnarzt, damit werde ich mich nicht beschäftigen mit den
widerlichen Arterien, ne, ich finde Adern schön, aber jedem, wie er mag, ich finde es spannend, vor allem finde ich es spannend, dass uns jemand wie Henning hört.
Ist das das Überthema heute, weil wir haben gesprochen über Flüsse, Strassen, Adern. Ist das unser Überthema heute? Heute ist grosse Versorgungssysteme. Ja, die grosse Logistikfolge. Die grosse, das Podcast UFO, Infrastruktur Systemefolge. Herr Tietze, Ihr Paket ist hier. Vielen Dank. das klärm aber schnell. Ja, wegen Logistik. Wie haben Sie das gemacht? Führen Sie mich durch Ihren Logistikweg.
Das ist ein Film von Slaughterville und Stefan Kieze.
Grosse Einbindung. Die Logistik.
Da war noch Platz für mehr, aber es ist ... Als Logistik bezeichnet man den Vorgang der Organisation und Weiterleitung von Waren. So, hi, ich stehe jetzt hier bei diesem Verteilerzentrum von DHL. Neben mir ist Herr Meierling. Hallo Herr Meierling.
Ja, guten Tag.
Vielen Dank, dass Sie in unserem Film mitmachen, in diesem Studentenfilm. Ich wollte gerne fragen, wie wissen Sie, wo Pakete hinkommen?
Ja, da gibt es ein Strichcodesystem, die kommen ja an in den Lastwagen, dann wird das gescannt rein, dann kommt was bei uns in die Regale und dann ... Es ist eine verrückte Welt. Ich verstehe es immer noch nicht, aber ich verstehe es auch. Es ist einfach weird. Ich wohne ja in der Nähe von einem DHL-Verteiler-Dings, wo dann morgens immer diese Herrscharen wie Sicario kommen,, in Kolonne fahren ganz viele DHL-Sicario?
Nein, ich schwöre dir, der ist eine bessere Referenz als du denkst. Du kannst Referenz nehmen, Star Wars, Herr der Ringe und Harry Potter, manchmal flucht der Karibik, aber nicht Sicario.
Nee, ich hätte es ja auch noch erklärt, in Kolonne fahren jedenfalls so 50 DHL-Autos in die Welt hinaus. Jeden Tag. Crazy, sieht so krass aus. Und das ist schon irre, dass überall auch so, deswegen geht es mir, wenn ich so New York-Videos sehe oder sowas, wie da jeder Mensch an jedem Tag seine Pakete bekommen kann, ist nämlich ein absolutes Rätsel. Aber kannst du Logistik verstehen, nur indem du den ganzen Tag diese Lagerhalle anstarrst?
Kannst du etwas verstehen, wenn du es nur lange genug beobachtest, ohne dass du reinguckst?
Ja.
Ja?
Ich glaube schon.
Ist ja auch alles kein Hexenwerk, man weiß ja ungefähr, was passiert.
Frage, warum machen wir nicht mehr aus Brieftauben? Ja, das sind jetzt die Richtige. Weil wir haben so viele Tauben in den Städten. So viele. Die sind alle arbeitslos. Die sind alle arbeitslos. Die suchen alle einen Job. Die suchen einen Job. Naja, und jetzt wäre mal die Frage, ne, also da ist ein CO2-neutraler Weg, um Briefe von A nach B zu bringen. Sehr, die pupsen ein bisschen, aber es ist nicht so, dass es jetzt so viel wie so eine Rinderherde wäre. Das finde ich jetzt nicht so schlimm. Ich sage, die bohren auch nicht so viel zu essen. Ich meine, die überleben in unseren dreckigen Innenstädten, in unseren dreckigen unaufgeräumten Innenstädten. Deswegen gibt man denen so Harry Potter-mässig, steckt man denen dann so einen Brief in den Schnabel und dann fliegen die dann dahin.
Geht doch.
Aber können die das dann auch in den Briefkasten tun?
Ja.
Früher ja.
Früher ja, jetzt nicht mehr.
Nein, die verlernt.
Die heutigen Tauben, die jugendlichen Tauben können das heute nicht mehr machen.
Diese Gen-Z-Tauben, die machen das nicht mehr.
Der ganze Tag mit ihrem Wordle, sie geben immer nur das Wort Taube ein. Ich vergleiche nur Wordle-Ergebnisse und immer Pitchen. Taube, stimmt nicht. Taube. Übrigens ist Taube kein schlechtes Wort als erstes für Wordle. Weil zwei Vokale drin sind, drei sogar. Ehe schon. Und als Podcast-Ufo-Hörerin wisst ihr eh schon, dass das N, das zweithäufig, das zweithäufigste Buchstabe der deutschen Sprache ist. Enis-Rabdul. Enis-Rabdul. Sind die häufigsten Buchstaben, E-I-N.
Genau.
Enis-Rabdul.
Dadurch wisst ihr schon mal mehr als der geneigte andere World-Spieler,
das, wie ihr vielleicht anfangen solltet.
Ich habe erst mal lächerlich lange gebraucht,
damit mir ein englisches Wort mit fünf Buchstaben einfällt.
Ich hatte immer Take, Senorita, Popcorn, Door, Sail, Car, Rose, Pig, Pigs, ne, Fig, Piggy, Piggy, Figgy. Und dann geht man ab und zu sowas ein, wo man denkt, könnte ein Wort sein und man nur so Kopfschütteln. Jesus. Aber ich habe auch häufig bei dem richtigen englischen Wort dann nicht, ich habe es schon mal gehört, aber ich habe jetzt nicht eine Hand erfüllungsvoll sehen können, was es bedeutet. Ich glaube, mittlerweile ist der Punkt, dass wir alle schlechter Englisch sprechen, als wir denken. Weil wir denken, wir können Englisch, weil wir uns die Filme angucken. Aber wenn mal jemand fragt, ja, was heißt eine Spitzhacke, was heißt ein Spachtel, was heißt ein Kronleuchter, was heißt ein Sellerie? Oh, so eine künstlerische Artige Richtung. Keine Ahnung. Das wissen wir alles nicht. Sellerie. Ja gut, Sellerie heißt Sellerie. Sellerie. Sellerie. Du musst nur ein bisschen Englisch aussprechen, das passt. Deswegen mochten die mich nicht. Ich wollte ehrlich immer über meine Salary sprechen, aber meine Chefin damals war super genervt, weil die dachte, ich will immer über die Salary sprechen. I want a bigger salary. You just started the job. No, please. I don't mind, I'm hungry. I want a bigger salary. I'm so hungry. I'm so hungry for more salary. And it's good for my Verdauungstrakt. It's so good for any, for, I will do a better job if you give me a much higher amount of salary. No, you get more than you deserve already. Also, you come to work late, you talk to the birds, you don't do your job. It's not healthy. It's healthy to give me more salary. In fact, everybody in this office should get a little bit more of salary. Don't do this crazy talk. Salary tea. Are you a communist? You're fired. Das war mein, habe ich nicht verstanden, warum. Zum Thema Logistik finde ich aber auch noch einen Punkt, wichtig in der Versorgungskette ist natürlich auch der letzte Schritt, die Entsorgung. Also da denken wir immer nicht gerne dran, wir bestellen uns ganz viel, freuen uns, dass wir es haben, packen es aus. Unvergessen dein sehr schlecht gealtertes, ich schmeiße einfach aus dem Fenster. Aus dem Fenster in den Container, du kannst nicht sagen. Ich habe damals in meiner Berlin-Zeit so gewohnt, dass ich aus meinem Fenster auf die Container blicken konnte.
Du kannst das jetzt nicht abkürzen als, du wirfst deinen Müll aus dem Fenster.
Es war das, was du getan hast. Ja, aber der Zielort ist relevant. Ich habe versucht, den Container zu treffen.
Ja, das ist mir ab und zu auch gelungen.
Das ist ein glückliches Resultat dessen.
Und wir denken aber oft bei dieser Versorgungslogistik hätte nicht
an die Entsorgung. Und damit denken wir auch selten
an Moritz.
Denn Moritz macht Mülltüten.
Mülltüten Moritz!
Und wir haben uns gefragt,
kann ein Mensch
cooler sein?
Nee, wir haben uns gefragt, kann ein Mensch, der
hauptberuflich etwas herstellt, was
sofort weggeschmissen wird? Du hast gesagt, wie könnt ihr mit euch leben? Ich habe gesagt, schämt euch! Ist es das, was ihr machen wollt, wie könnt ihr mit euch leben, schämen, schämen, schämen? Damit wollt ihr euer Leben verbringen, Dinge herzustellen, die sofort weggeschmissen werden. Und Moritz liefert eine Gegenposition. Er schreibt, seit über drei Jahren bin ich nur in dem Müllbeutelgeschäft und mein schlechter Schlaf liegt eher an meinen beiden kleinen Söhnen. Hier ein kleines Rechenbeispiel, mit dem ich mir den von dir beschriebenen Müllbeutel stolz rationalisiert habe. Beispiel Hamburg. Hier gibt es circa eine Million Haushalte. Angenommen, jeder Haushalt verbraucht pro Woche einen 60 Liter Beutel, dann sind das eine Million Haushalte mal 52 Wochen, a zehn Beutel pro Rolle, vierzig Rollen pro Karton, sechzig Kartons pro Palette, ein Beutel pro Tag, ein Beutel pro Woche. Einunddreißig Paletten pro Lkw ist gleich siebzig Lkws voll mit Müllbeuteln pro Jahr für Hamburger Haushalte. Und das ist allein die Menge an Kunststoff, um den eigentlichen Müll zu entsorgen. Immerhin machen wir unsere Müllbeutel aus Müll, über 90% recycelten Kunststoff, aus der Wertstoffsammlung. Zugegeben, das Müllbeutelgeschäft ist wenig sexy, und Stolz ist ein sehr großes Wort, aber als etwas Sinnstiftendes empfinde ich es schon, einen kleinen Beitrag zur Kreislaufwirtschaft leisten zu können. Wenn ich dann schon nicht stolz ins Bett gehe abends, dann wenigstens einmal die Woche mit dem Podcast Ufo. Wow. Das ist schön, das ist nett, danke Moritz. Aber auch, ja, aber du sagst auch, ich entschuldige, jeder Schwerverbrecher kann entspannt ins Bett gehen, wenn er das Podcast-Ufo hört. So wollen wir nicht verwendet werden. Wir wollen euch nicht von euren Gewissensbisten entlasten. Ich ein bisschen. Wir wollen euch zur Rechenschaft, nee, ich will euch zur Rechenschaft ziehen. Ihr seid hiermit zur Rechenschaft gezogen jetzt. Ich meine, wenn man so einen Mord begangen hat, dann vergessen auch oft Leute, dass man dann vielleicht nicht so gut schlafen kann abends. Ja? Da kommen wir ins Spiel. Wir geben, wir geben, naja, bist du dir wirklich sicher, dass du die Mörder als neue Zielgruppe dieses Podcasts aktivieren willst? Nein, nicht als Hauptzielgruppe. Ich sage nur, dass der Nebeneffekt ist, dass wir denen auch helfen, einzuschlafen. Und man oft vergisst, was für Nervenaufreibende für ein Nervenaufreibender Kraftaktes auch ist manchmal. Auch so eine Leiche verschwinden lassen, dadurch unterschätzt man, dass man die nicht einfach loswirft. Stell dir mal vor, ich will dich mal sehen, wie du dem Car2Go so eine Leiche wegbringst. Ja. Angenommen, da ist irgendwas passiert, ein schlimmes Unglück zwischen uns. So irgendwie, wir verstreiten uns, du willst anderthalb Stunden aufnehmen, ich sag, nee, Podcast reicht eine Stunde, mehr aufgesehen hat man nicht. Unsere Zuhörer wollen mehr. Nee, aber ich finde, es ist der Streit und deine Markeflasche landet an meiner Schläfe und ich sack zu Boden. Okay. Du willst dann nicht zugeben, dass du mich umgebracht hast. Oder willst du sofort zur Polizei gehen? nein. So, jetzt hast du aber kein Auto, du hast nur ein Car to go vor der Tür stehen, was noch geparkt ist. Dann, wie kriegst du meinen, ist ja auch nicht leicht. Naja, in der ersten Phase ist es ja leicht, weil noch keine Leichenstarre eingesetzt hat. Das heißt, ich kann dich marionettenhaft quasi bewegen. Ich lege einfach deinen Arm an meine Schulter und sage, oh Mensch, haben wir gestern viel getrunken, oder? Und dann laufe ich, binde ich vielleicht sogar deinen linken Fuss an meinen rechten, so dass du so mitläufst. Und dann sag ich so, ach, jetzt steig dir der Strike erstmal ein, Buddy. Klopf dir hinten auf den Rücken. Die ersten Menschen werden misstrauisch, die dich kennen. Komm, jetzt setz dich erstmal hin, Bro. Setz dich auf den Beifahrersitz, schnall dich an. Sicherheit geht vor. Die Polizei wird aufmerksam, wenn dir die Leiche nicht angeschnallt ist, weil da denken die, Moment mal, warum liegt ihm die Sicherheit nicht im Herzen? Die Polizei wird immer misstrauisch, wenn die Leichen nicht angeschnallt sind. Ja, und dann will ich einfach zwei Stunden aus der Stadt fahren und irgendeine Autobahnraststätte und nicht in den Container werfen. Bitte nochmal? Autobahnradstätte ist, glaube ich, der beste Platz. Und da sind Container. Ja. Da sind Container für viel Müll. Da habe ich schon entsorgt. Huiuiui, habe ich da entsorgt. Du unterschätzt auch, wie dich Bevölkerung Deutschland ist. Das mag sein. Das ist eine Kritik, die lasse ich mir gerne gefallen. Nee, du kommst weg. Du kommst weg. Du kommst weg. Einfach in so ein Waldstück, dann verbrennen und dann das. Also sorry, ich will es nicht so ausheben lassen, als wäre das super leicht. Aber es ist schon leicht. Aber ich finde es gut. Also vielen Dank und sorry, nochmal im Namen von Florentin, dass die Berufsgruppe so ein bisschen das Fett wegbekommen hat. Weil ich fand es ja nach wie vor einen soliden, coolen Job, der uns hilft, unsere Welt sauber zu halten.
Mülltüten.
Ach so.
Mülltüten, Moritz.
Nee, finde ich gut, finde ich richtig.
Und ansonsten vielen Dank auch für die ganzen Einsendungen zum Thema Bahnruheabteil.
Ja.
Da tut sich was im Untergrund, der Untergrund rumort.
Aber noch ist nichts passiert.
Ich hatte eine harte Woche, ich hatte viel auf dem Schreibtisch, weil ich habe ein bisschen an das gedacht, was du gesagt hast vor ein paar Wochen. Okay, was habe ich gesagt? Ich habe mir das nochmal durch den Kopf gehen lassen, was du damals gesagt hast. Was habe ich denn gesagt? Irgendwie, man geht ja von so einer Aufnahme nach Hause und oft ist ja viel auch schon weg. Ja, damit kann ich relaten. Und manche Sachen bleiben aber hängen, wo du einfach so immer wieder drauf kommst, so wenn du in deinem Kopf stöberst und du denkst, da hat er recht, da hat er echt recht. Und du hast gesagt, dass das Haribo-Maskottchen dieser kleine Junge ist, von Colorado. Das hast du mitgenommen. Dieser kleine Colorado-Junge. Moment, jetzt kurz, nach allen Folgen, die wir zusammen aufgenommen haben, wo viele Sachen gesagt wurden, viele cleverere Sachen auch, natürlich auch viele doofe Sachen, klar. Mit der Abschaffung der Städte, das war Ausrutscher. Aber was du mitgenommen hast, ist, dass ich behauptet habe, der ist das Maskottchen von Haribo wäre der kleine schwarzhaarige Junge. Und dann habe ich ein bisschen recherchiert, dann bin ich da nochmal, weil ich konnte nicht schlafen. Drei Uhr nachts lag ich wach und habe nochmal richtig gegraben und habe herausgefunden, dass es zwei Haribo-Maskottchen gibt. Es gibt viele, aber die Hauptmaskottchen sind der Goldbeer und der schwarzhaarige Junge. Aber auf manchen Packungen ist der schwarzhaarige Junge, auf anderen nicht. Und erst dachte ich, ich habe das Rätsel geknackt. Weil die Frage war, auf welchen Packungen ist der Goldbeer? Alles, was Lakritz beinhaltet, hat nämlich den schwarzhaarigen Jungen. Und jetzt pass auf, ich hatte Colorado, die Lakritzschnecken und ich dachte, Moment mal, überall wo Lakritze drin ist, ist der schwarzhaarige Junge drauf.
Und dann dachte ich mir, das ist ja genial. Das ist die Verbindung. Ich finde gut, wie ominös das klingt. Der schwarzhaarige Junge. Das sind auch so wie Sherlock Holmes und der schwarzhaarige Junge. Harry Potter ist der schwarzhaarige Junge. Harry Potter ist der schwarze Junge, Der langweilige, der sehr, sehr langweilige, faktenbasierte Teil 8. Beschreibungsroman. Und ich habe auch keinen Namen zu dem gefunden. Und deswegen würde ich hier vorschlagen, ihn zu benennen in Lars Kritze. Lars Kritze soll der schwarzhaarige Junge heißen, der auf allen Packungen ist mit Lakeritze. Auf allen ausser Kolorat. So, wir haben ein paar Probleme mit der Theorie. Es gibt kleine Probleme und es gibt grosse Probleme. Ich bin übrigens für Lars Titze. Okay, finde ich auch nicht schlecht. Lars Kritze oder Lars Titze? Ja. Ja. Da gibt es einen Vornamen, der mit K endet. Mark Titze. Nee, ich finde Lars Kritze schon auch gut. Graf Titze. Irgendwie sowas finden wir schon. Und auf jeden Fall, es gibt kleine Probleme. Und zwar, es gibt ja die LakritzSchnecken. Die gibt es aber auch noch in nicht-lakritzig. Also die gleiche Form, die gleiche Schneckenform, aber mit Fruchtgummi. Auf der Packung. Und der schwarzhaarige Junge. Da kann man jetzt sagen, gut. Ist der da drauf? Ja, der ist da drauf, auf dem Fahrrad. Da kann man sagen, das ist ein Ableger von der Schnecke. Ein Spin-Off eines Lakritz-Produktes. Was ist mit Piratos? Weiß ich nie, was das ist. Und es klingt so, als müsste ich wissen, was es ist. Das sind die Goldminzen aus Lakritze. Piratos. Was da drauf? Pirat. Ist es denn der schwarzhaarige Junge mit Piraten? Nein, nein, nein. Aber könnte es eine Weiterentwicklung des schwarzhaarigen J 40 Jahre später sein, nach einem sehr harten Leben, könnte er Pirat geworden sein. Oder nach so einem Will Turner-artigen Inziden. Ja, stimmt, kann auch sein. Er ist ein neuer Piratenkapitän. Und natürlich Pinguine. Die meiner Meinung nach vergessenste Klassikersorte von Haribo ist nämlich die geniale Kombination Zitrone und Lakritze, oft verlacht, oft übersehen. Der Pinguin besteht aus Schwarz und Weiss, Lakritze und Zitrone. Auch da auf der Packung abgebildet ein Pinguin, nicht Lars Kritze. Aber ich finde, das sind schon Freiheiten, künstlerische Freitzen, die Sinn ergeben und durchaus auch Spaß machen. Wenn ich jetzt die Pirates oder Pinguine möchte, dann will ich auch einen Piratenverpacken haben. Aber du hast es doch selber gesagt, gib doch dem schwarzhaarigen Jungen einen Piratenhut und einen Säbel in die Hand. Wie machst du denn bei den Pinguinen? Soll er da auf einer Arktis herumschwimmen mit den Pinguinen oder was? Ja, aber sie gibt den so einen Wrack an. Ja, oder lass den doch auf einem Pinguin reiten oder der hebt so zwei Pinguine hoch. Also Piratos geschenkt, dem gebe ich dir. Da muss er, er muss die Augenklappe bekommen. Er muss den Papageien auf der Schulter haben. Er muss den Piratenhut haben. Er muss den, es gibt viel zu viele Dinge, die auf Piraten passen. Ja, können wir da mal ein paar abwerfen, über Bord werfen? Wir müssen da ein paar über Bord werfen. Er muss auf der Planke stehen. Er muss diesen Hakenarm haben. Es ist zu viel. Er muss das Holzbein haben. Der schwarzhaarige Junge muss der mit der Piratenflagge da oben sein. Auf dem Schiff, am Steuerrad. Er ist auf der Flagge. Er ist auf der Flagge mit zwei Knochen, finde ich, an die Stürmer. Er muss den Säbel haben. Die Piraten sind so lächerlich überausgestattet. Ich finde auch, wenn die internationale Piratenorganisation so ein Statement rausgibt und sagt, wir werfen Augenklappe und Holzbein ab. Wir haben jetzt nur noch Haken und Hut und Papagei. Müssen wir nicht drüber sprechen. Weil das muss weg. Wir haben zu viel. Wir geben das jetzt den Rittern. Die Ritter kriegen jetzt Holzbein und Augenklappe. Die haben auch schon sehr viel. Ja, die tragen 80 Kilo. Cowboys tragen jetzt Augenklappe. Die haben auch schon zu viel. Die haben nicht so viel, nur einen Hut. Wer nichts hat, Astronaut. Ja, die haben einen riesigen Anzug und einen Alien oder so. Astronauten kriegen Augenklappen, Holzbeine und Papageien. Lass uns sagen, dann kriegen die Astronauten die Augenklappe und die Zauberer vielleicht Holzbeine. Weil die haben eh eine lange Robe an. Ipze Dio. Okay, alles klar, haben wir doch. Guck mal, und alle stehen so auf, diese Maskottchen, alle stehen auf in einem grossen Gremium und sagen, gut, wunderbar. Und da ist natürlich die Frage, also das sind jetzt die grossen Probleme, Lars Kritze ist nicht auf allen. Es gibt aber noch ein anderes Gegenbeispiel und ich werde da dranbleiben. Weil natürlich, wenn man an Haribo-Mischungen denkt, denkst du natürlich an Colorado. Ich denke an Colorado. Warum nicht an Starmix?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Aha.
These, Starmix ist die bessere Haribo-Mischung als Colorado.
Starmix, zum Beispiel, du hast das Spiegelei.
Nein.
Du hast das geile Spiegelei.
Und da hast du nicht so gut.
Aber die Spiegelei sind mega gut.
Du kannst die auch separat kaufen.
Was auf der Spiegeleipackung?
Das weiss ich nicht tatsächlich.
Das ist ein sehrile Spiegelei. Nein. Und in der Regel ist es nicht so gut, aber die Spiegelei sind mega gut. Du kannst die auch separat kaufen. Was auf der Spiegeleitpackung? Das weiß ich nicht tatsächlich. Lars Kritze. Und das Problem ist, Starmix natürlich abgebildet, wer ist auf Starmix abgebildet? Der Goldbär. Der Goldbär. Und zwar eine Rakete, Starmix. Und er ist abgebildet auf allen Packungen. Und ich denke, das ergibt Sinn, weil da ist keine Lakritze drin, also ist der schwarzhaarige Junge da nicht drauf. Aber Starmix, Minipacks, die kleinen Packungen. Nein, hör auf. Wer sitzt mit in der Rakete? Fucking Glass-Kritze. Fucking Glass-Kritze. Mit den Goldbeeren zusammen? Mit den Goldbeeren zusammen. Das ist der einzige Moment, wo man beide gleichzeitig sieht? Ja. Auf den Starmix-Minipackungen? StMix-Minipackungen, aber auch nur auf manchen. Und jetzt frage ich mich, was ist da passiert? Wer hat da seinen Job nicht gemacht bei Haribo, dass in irgendwelchen Einzelpackungen Lars Kritze abgebildet wurde, bis irgendjemand eingeschritten ist aus Corporate und gesagt hat, Leute, Lars Kritze ist doch nur auf Lakritz-Packungen drauf, der muss raus aus der Rakete. Aber das ist gedruckt, ich habe Fotos gesehen, es gibt Fehldruck-Packungen, wo auf Starmix-Minipacks Lars Kritze mit im Raumschiff sitzt. So, und jetzt wird es nämlich spannend, weil jetzt würde ich vorschlagen, in den nächsten Folgen fahren wir gemeinsam nach Bonn. Ja. Haribo, Hans, Riegel, Bonn. Er hat den Hinweis schon gegeben in seinem Produktnamen, also der erste Schritt ist schon getan. Also ich wüsste jetzt, wo man anfangen sollte, so Illuminati-mäßig, Sakrileg, Vermächtigste Tempelritter, wir haben den ersten Brotkrumen bekommen, der Hinweis liegt dem Namen, Bo, Bon. Bon. Oder? Harry Bon. Bodelburg. Aber wir werden jetzt die Städte mit Bonn, also ich würde, lass uns in Bonn anfangen. Wir hören erst auf, wenn wir die Antwort haben, was Lars Kritze auf den fucking Packungen zu suchen hat, wo keiner Kritze nicht. Irgendwie musst du das immer entschieden haben, weil es gibt ja zwei Ausnahmen von der Regel. Es gibt einmal Lars Kritze auf einer Packung, also zwei Beispiele auf einer Packung, wo er nicht die Fruchtschnecken und Starmix Minimpacks. Genau. Was ist da los? Unabhängig davon würde ich auch einfach mal gerne bei so einem Haribo-Fabrik stehen. Ja, das riecht mich gut. Nee, ich will mich über den Schornstein hängen. Ich will mich, du kannst da... Ich glaube, da ist jene Hängematte. Du machst die Recherche so... Du machst gar nichts. Ich hänge so Arme ausgestreckt über dem Schornstein und atme diese Zuckerdämpfe ein. Wie geil. Ja, finde ich gut. Verwechselst aber mit dem, der für die Heizung der Büros zuständig ist und dann gebe ich um. Ich hätte gerne eine Stunde in der Hängematte über dem Schornstein, bitte. Kein Problem. Ich finde es magisch. Ging es schon jemals jemandem schlecht in der Hängematte? War jemand mal wütend in der Hängematte? Ich glaube ja, weil alle freuen sich darauf, sich hineinzulegen. Ich nehme mir jetzt mal die Zeit, mich da reinzulegen. Oh, heute habe ich mal einen freien Tag, Arbeit ist getan, und dann ist man immer enttäuscht davon, wie unbequem und was für eine doofe Idee das auch eigentlich Videos. Wo kommt es denn her? Es kommt ja nicht daher, sich mal auszuruhen und sich einzukokonieren und Spaß zu haben. Nee, Schifffahrt. Es kommt daher, dass man nicht, genau, Schifffahrt, damit man gerade bleibt immer, oder damit man nicht auf dem Waldboden, auf dem Dschungelboden schlafen muss, wo die ganzen fiesen Tiere und Skorpione, die in den Arsch schwächen. Du hast völlig recht, Hängematte hat nichts mit Entspannung zu tun. Nee, es ist überleben. Wie konnte uns die Hängematte-Lobby dazu überzeugen, dass es ein entspannteres Liegewerkzeug ist? Ja, es kommt ein bisschen halt von diesen Bildern, diese typischen, diese Wordart ist glaube ich das Problem. Wordpress. Dieses Problem. Wordart? Ja, diese Sticker-Vereinfachungen von so Palmen, wo dann so eine Hängematte dazwischen ist. Wo Hängematte assoziiert wurde irgendwann mit Urlaub und Palmen und Spaß und Strand. Da kommt das her. Falsch. Falsch. Überlegst du mal, was du... Das ist furchtbar. Hängematten sind wirklich schrecklich. Und dann läuft man auf und dann ist die ganze Rückseite in diesem Hängemattenmuster, in diesem gitterförmigen Ding. Das will man ja nicht. Aber Stichwort Pirat hat zu viele Gadgets.
Wir sind jetzt kurz vor Karneval. Wenn diese Folge rauskommt, ist schon, beziehungsweise ist man kurz vor Karneval. Februar. Und ich habe mir jetzt ein Kostüm kaufen müssen, weil ich bin bei einer Karnevalsfeier eingeladen, im kleinen Kreis mit Leuten und muss mir jetzt ein Kostüm kaufen. Und ich bin, wir sind gerade in Berlin und ich bin immer so spät dran und vergesse das immer, mir ein Kostüm zu besorgen und so. Und dann, eigentlich wollte ich dieses Jahr so ein cooler Wikinger sein. So ein cooles Kostüm, was so ein bisschen zu übertrieben in so eine Lab-Richtung geht. Also schon ein cooles Wikinger-Kostüm, das passt irgendwie. Und war alles zu spät, hätte nicht mehr hingehauen und so weiter. Und jetzt hatte ich schon die Angst, dass ich mir so ein Basic-Ass-Kostüm kaufen muss mit so, ja, keine Ahnung, Spiderman oder der schwarzhaarige Junge. So, das will man ja nicht. Und deswegen bin ich dann jetzt in Berlin in so einen coolen Kostümladen gegangen, was natürlich das Coolste ist, weil in Köln könnte man jetzt kein Kostüm mehr bekommen und es wäre wahnsinnig voll und es ist das nervigste Einkaufserlebnis der Welt. Und hier war entspannt, hier in Berlin war komplett der Lehrerladen und da war eine super coole Frau, die auch so glaube ich aus so einem Lab-Kontext kam und dann mit mir zusammen gebrainstuffed hat, was man da machen kann. Und was ich natürlich gesehen habe, bin ich die extrem riesige Auswahl an Masken und Hüten und so durchgegangen. Und was mir sofort ins Auge gestochen ist, war dieser tolle, dreizackige Piratenhut. Mit dieser riesengroßen, schönen, hellen Feder haben ihn aufgesetzt. Und es war wie Harry Potter am Anfang bei Ollivander, wenn er den richtigen Zauberstab bekommt. Und von unten kommt dann so ein Gebläse und dann so ein Strahl auf dich und das ist es. Weil so war es ein bisschen, als ich den Hut aufgedrückt habe. Es war ein Match, es war mein Hut. Das überrascht mich jetzt auch nicht sehr, dass du den Piratenhut gut fandest. Ich war eher so ein bisschen gelangweilt, dass das jetzt das ist, was zu mir passt. Schattet ihr die Piratenphase, so wie 2008? Nee, und ich habe noch nie ein gutes Piratenkostüm gehabt, bin auch noch nie Karneval oder irgendwann mal Halloween als Pirat gegangen, von daher fand ich es schön, es ist Zeit, es ist basic, aber es hat auch Zeit. Und dann haben sie mir den perfekten Piratenmantel, hat sie mir noch gegeben und irgendwann, es sah super aus, alles war daran mega cool und dann hat sie mir noch einen Säbel gegeben und das war auch fantastisch, dann hat sie mir noch so ein Undershirt gegeben, mega geil, dann den Papageien auf der Schulter, okay, dann hat sie mir dann so ein... Und du hast gefragt, aber wo ist jetzt der Haken? Und sie gibt dir den Haken. Sie hat mir den Haken gegeben. Dann hat sie mir noch so eine Tüte besorgt mit so Goldmünzen als Gag, dass man sagen kann, hier ein Kölsch zum Beispiel und dann schmeißt man einfach diesen Goldsack auf den Tisch. Ah, okay, und dann sagt er, nee, wirklich, es kostet zwei Euro. Nee, wirklich kostet zwei Euro und ich sage, haha, und dann sage ich was Piratenmässiges. Okay, also das, da fehlt's noch. Dann eine Piratenhose, dann Rüschen-Shirt, ne, und dann Holzbein und dann diese großen Stiefel und es wurde immer mehr, und daher kam auch mein Gedanke, Piraten haben zu viel Klamm. Ja, viel zu viel Zeug. Und dann habe ich so gesagt, und dann ist die Frage, eine Augenklappe, wo hört man auf? Aber ich mir diese Augenklappe habe ich dann noch mitgenommen, weil ich dachte, ich kann jetzt, ich muss entscheiden zwischen den ganzen Gadgets, ich muss davon, ich muss diese zwei von fünf Gadgets muss ich nehmen, sonst hat diese arme Frau mir zu viel gebracht. Also habe ich mich dann entschieden für Säbel und Augenklappe. Jetzt das Problem ist, habe ich die Augenklappe mal zu Hause aufgesetzt und nach zwei Sekunden geht einem das tierisch auf den Nerven, dass man kein räumliches Empfinden mehr hat. Das ist das Erste, was man bereut am Karnevalsabend, ist, dass man ständig irgendwo gegen Sachen läuft. Ich werde auf jeden Fall diese Augenklappe nicht benutzen. Weg mit der Augenklappe, dafür Papagei. Ich würde sagen, Papagei ist ein No-Brainer, kannst du gut mitspielen, oder der Papagei hat die Augenklappe. Wenn du die jetzt schon hast, dann setz dir doch so einen Stoffpapagei auf die Schulter, der hat die Augenklappe, ist ein Lacher, ist ein Gag und du bist eigentlich der Gewinner. Ich bin Hot Pirate. Also ich finde es super, ich finde es richtig gut geworden. Wo kommt das Hot jetzt her? Ich. Also das war das Kostüm, ist ein bisschen freizügiger, oder? So, ich zeige es dir jetzt mal. Ich zeige es dir kurz. Wow! Wow! Das sieht ja gar nicht so nach Klischee-Pirat aus. Ich hatte jetzt zu Captain Hook so ein roter Mantel und so, aber nein, es sieht wirklich, also kann gut sein, dass du da auch aufgegriffen wirst von der Kripo. Also es sieht doch einfach, und dann die Stiefel da unten. Also es ist farblich, was alles. Die Hose auch und diese Stutzen unten, das ist ja schon, da ist ja auch mal wirklich auch was ausgegeben. Naja, also die Hose ist meine private Piratenhose, aber ich, ja, also was ich daran sehr mag, ist irgendwie, dass man da jetzt nicht versucht, irgendeinen Pirat darzustellen, sondern ich bin mein eigener Pirat. Du bist nicht der klassische Pirat, auch nicht jetzt mit dem großen Brauschebart, du bist halt eher so junger Pirat. Du bist eher so Will Turner-mäßig. Ich bin der Will Turner, der auch noch nicht genau weiß, wie sprechen Stiefel eben, der kommt erst mal rein. Also der... Arrg! Aber er hat schon so vielleicht eine Mission und das Geile ist ja, du kannst ja die ganze... Also ich bin ja eh zu Hause in der Pirates of the Caribbean Welt und kann dann diese ganze Tortuga-Nummer machen. Und ich heuere gerade an und willst du... Ich brauche die beste Crew. Und die ganzen drei Sprüche, die ich habe und kann, die würde ich dann einfach den ganzen Abend zitieren. Ich glaube, es wird cool. Also aber du gehst jetzt nicht so in die Jack Sparrow-Richtung, sondern eher so ehrlicher, vertrauenswürdiger Pirat, der aber noch irgendwie einen geheimen Plan im Hinterkopf hat, sowas in der Richtung. Also du hast eine komplette Backstory. Ich werde mir eine elaborierte Backstory ausdenken und nach zwei Kölsch vergessen. Alles klar. Das ist wahrscheinlich der Plan. Aber ich freue mich sehr darauf und dann war es halt so, dass ich dann in Berlin mit dieser großen Tüte Karnevalsurteile, wo oben diese große Feder von diesem Hut rausragte, also die große Tüte dabei. Und in Köln wäre das normal, eher auch gehört zum guten Ton. Hier in Berlin waren alle verwirrt, was ich da gekauft habe, weil da diese riesige Feder hinten aus dieser Tüte ragte. Aber gut. Und was ist das jetzt für ein Säbel? Ist das so ein Lab-Schaumstoff-Säbel? Oder was ist das? Das ist so ein richtiger boring-ass-Gummi-Säbel. Okay. Aber auch cool. Macht auch Spaß damit, rumzutanzen, Leuten das unter die Nase zu halten. Und dann noch so eine Rumflasche, so mit so 3x drauf. Ah, finde ich auch super, eine Rumflasche. Ich würde auch immer hinter die Bar greifen, dann so eine grosse Flasche nehmen, Korken, den Mund rausziehen, einen Schluck nehmen und dann so in die Bar färben. Also ich glaube, es wird schwankt zwischen Spaß und Hausfriedensbruch. Ich bin immer noch fasziniert, dass deine erste Idee Wikinger war. Da hätte ich dich überhaupt nicht gesehen. Nein? Nee, gar nicht. Nein? Aber hätte ich dich nicht gedacht, dass sich das fasziniert.
Ich habe dich und die Wikingerwelt gar nicht überschnitten gesehen.
Kam ja damals bei meinem Gentest auch aus, dass ich von den Wikingern abstamme.
Und seitdem bin ich großer Fan von mir.
Nee, aber weiß ich jetzt nicht. Warum denn nicht?
Ich bin doch ...
Ich hatte dich jetzt eher so Samurai-Ninja-mässig gesehen, dachte ich. Weil du bist ja schon recht agil. Also du bist jetzt nicht so der Berserker-Muskelprotz, sondern wenn, dann eher auf Schnelligkeit, oder? Ja. Also du hättest dann eher so Gewandtheits-Stats geskillt und nicht Stärke. Okay, ja. Ist ja auch gut, ist ja auch gut, aber es ist halt so, naja, aber also. Auch nicht. Ich habe mir noch nicht überlegt, was ich zu Karneval mache, weil ich werde nicht hingehen. Ah ja. Deswegen interessiert es mich auch nicht. Ich finde es nach wie vor ein schönes Fest. Klar, dieses Jahr ist die Frage, wie gross man das alles machen sollte. Aber generell ist es ein tolles Fest, wo Menschsein gefeiert wird. Alle sind Freunde, alles ist erlaubt. Ist doch toll. Ja, und es ist auch so ein bisschen so ein Zeitgeist-Thermometer, wo man immer sagen kann, was sind die aktuellen Trends. Weil es gibt ja immer so saisonale Sachen. Ja, Squid Game. Squid Game, genau so was, wo du dann dabei bist. Nee, nicht so was. Alle gehen als Squid Game. Alle gehen als Squid Game? Ich glaube, dieses Jahr gehen alle als Squid Game und ich als Pirat. Und da hört auch meine Rollspiel. Und alle haben diese Musik auch. Ja, meine Rollspielkünste hören ja genau da auf. Wie reagiere ich jetzt, weil ich habe mir eine krasse Backstory überlegt, aber dann kommen natürlich die ganzen Squid Game Leute vor mir. Ist nicht so, wie soll ich mit denen reden? Ja, auss von Tortuga funktioniert deine Backstory nicht mehr so gut. Und jetzt bist du halt irgendwie mit den Leuten. Ausserhalb von der Truhe des Cortes oder der Insel, die niemals gefunden werden kann, ausser man weiss schon, wo sie existiert. Und Tortuga habe ich nichts. Aber vielleicht findest du so einen anderen, der auch Pirat ist. Und ihr tut euch dann zusammen für den Rest des Abends. Und einfach sagst so, ich bin der Captain. Ich bin der Captain. Ja, ich bin der Captain. Mit dem habe ich das zu tun. Schiff ist nicht genug Platz für zwei Captions. Ja. Willst du noch einen Erdnussflip? Nee, ich bin gespannt. Du sagst, du prophezeist, dass Squid Game ist das grosse Ding. Ich glaube, das Rad der Zeit wird auch richtig einschlagen. Das Rad der Zeit? Das Rad der Zeit, aktuell laufende Fantasy-Serie auf Amazon und ich glaube, das wird richtig einschlagen. Das wird ein Riesending. Alle tragen diese charakteristischen weiße Kleidung von diesen Inquisitorentypen und so und ich glaube, das wird ein Riesending. Also mit den Drachen-Prophezeiungen, wer ist der Drachen-Prophezeiung du noch einmal sagst, wenn du zu Sicario sagst, dass es eine Kack-Referenz ist, wenn du noch einmal das Rad der Zeit als Referenz herholst, dann flippe ich aus. Bist du schon mal ausgeflippt eigentlich? Bist du schon mal so richtig ausgeflippt? Ich habe ein paar harte Tage hinter mir, weil ich bin sehr viel gereist und mit Sturm und Zug fährt nicht und Mietwagen und hin und her und so. Dann bist du ausgefilft. Und Technik treibt mich immer an den Rand der Verzweiflung, gerade wenn man so Carsharing-Sachen hat, wo man immer aufs Internet angewiesen ist. Und dann bist du in einer Stadt, wo du kein Internet hast und dann musst du immer hin und her laufen und dann ist das Auto aber zu weit weg. Und dann kannst du nicht öffnen und denkst dir, wenn ich jetzther ans Auto gehe, dann habe ich kein Internet mehr, dann geht gar nichts mehr, dann läufst du
hin und her und hin und her und dann merkst du,
die Zeit läuft ab jetzt und dann gehst du zu einem anderen Auto
und dann ist das weg und die Reservierung abgelaufen und das ist
alles furchtbar und da kann dann schon mal so
ein verdammt noch eins.
Echt jetzt?
Ich glaube, mein Problem ist, dass ich
in Extremsituationen sehr
schnell in Selbstmitleid und Selbsthass
abdrifte, was nicht so cool ist. Ja, ich werde eher sehr weinerlich und ach, ich will es auch noch und kann nicht mal eins funktionieren. Weißt du, was das Schlimmste ist, wenn man ich werde dann eher wütend und dann fluchig und hau dann auch ab und so, er stot sich Flüche aus und wenn ich mich dabei verspreche, dann lose ich mein Shit. Kennt man das, das Gefühl, wenn man wütend ist, flucht und sich verspricht, es gibt nichts schlimmeres, schlimmeres, oh fuck! Es gibt nichts demütigenderes, obwohl es niemand hört, aber trotzdem denkst du, warum klappt nicht mal das jetzt? Ich hasse mich so sehr dann, dann wird es auch nur Selbsthass. Bei mir schlägt es wie gesagt nicht in Wut, sondern in ganz ekelhaftes Selbstmitleiden und fast würmiges Winden im Autositze. Warum kann denn nicht einmal was funktionieren und ich wäre bereit, in den Mutterleib zurückzukriechen, weil ich mich einfach so zu einem häufigen Elend selber gemacht habe und ich eigentlich der Welt zeigen will, wie schlecht es mir geht. Und ich bin hier mit drei fucking Beuteln unterwegs und dann bleibe ich irgendwie hängen und kann ihn nicht ausziehen und dann will ich auch, dass alle sehen, wie unglaublich schwer mein Leben ist. Dann versuchst du auch extra nochmal, dass er irgendwo hängen bleibt und du präparierst das so. Genau, extra nochmal und extra nochmal, jetzt habe ich mir die Schulter ausgekugelt und all das. Was willst du damit erreichen, dass Leute zu dir kommen und sagen, kann ich ihm helfen oder so? Nee, dass Leute einfach sehen, ja, der hat es echt nicht leicht. Der hat eine echt schwere Lage gerade. Das Schicksal ist wirklich nicht fertig. Aber du bist doch Schauspieler. Armen Mensch. Du bist doch Schauspieler. Sind das nicht Menschen, die die ganze Zeit so spielen, eher als wäre alles gut und eher von außen hin eher sagen wollen, nee, am fine. Ja, wie gesagt, in den Extremsituationen will ich dann, das ist jetzt nicht so, oh, wie blöd die Technik ist, das ist nicht meine Schuld, ich will die Schuld weg von mir lenken und sagen, oh, seht ihr nicht, wie schwer dieser Beutel ist, oh, die Schnur von meinem Pullover verheddert sich, oh, wie hart ist das Leben, ich bin so ein armer Tropf. Ganz unangenehm, ganz unangenehm, mag ich auch nicht.
Aber ist auch niemand angenehm.
Nee, ja, ich weiss nicht, es gibt schon, ich denke mir so, Wut, glaube ich, ist eine würdevollere Reaktion als dieses selbst verwurmende, ich liege am Boden und wälze mich herum am Hauptbahnhof, wenn der Zug Verspätung hat. Verspätung schon wieder und immer ich. Und warum denn kann nicht einmal was funktionieren? Einmal in meinem Leben muss das Car togo doch einfach aufgehen, doch die Internetverbindung ist nicht da. Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, Verspätung, nur etsch, nur etsch, nur etsch, nur zwei G.
Wo ist meine Maske? Der Test ist noch nicht da, die Maske fiel in die Pütze. Warum kannze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, fütze, es ist okay. Es ist hart, aber man weiß ja nicht, es könnte schwerer sein. Man weiß ja nicht, welchen Schwierigkeitsgrad man ausgewählt hat. Das ist häufig so, man hat keine Referenz. Ich war mit einem Arzt und der hat auch gefragt, wie es mir so geht. Und er hat so ein paar Dinge, körperliche Funktionen abgefragt und so. Und ich war immer überfordert, bei jeder Frage habe ich gedacht, keine Referenz. Ich erinnere mich. Können Sie gut atmen? Weiß ich nicht. Vielleicht ginge mehr. Aber er war immer so der Meinung, glaube ich, dass wenn man sich nicht beschwert, dann wird es schon okay sein. Aber das ist doch kein Maßstab fürs Leben. Also für nichts ist das ein Maßstab. Aber ich glaube, die meisten Sachen funktionieren einigermaßen, aber man kann es schlecht bewerten. Alle Sachen können schlecht bewerten. Sind sie leistungsfähig beim Sport? Weiß ich nicht. Glaube ich nicht, aber weiß ich nicht. Vielleicht ist es immer schwer. Ist ja nicht so, dass irgendwie Leute, die Biathlon machen oder so, dann nicht schwer atmen oder so. Und die denken doch auch manchmal, oh Gott, jetzt so viel latschen und laufen und dann auch schiessen. Also, weiß ich nicht, ob die, ob nicht alle Menschen... Das Schiessen, ich bin doch schon so außer Atem. Mein Brustkorb hebt und senkt sich und ich muss jetzt noch stillhalten. War tatsächlich mit meiner Cousine so, leidenschaftliche Langläuferin. Bierathletin. Langlaufen. Stimmt. Und deswegen musste sie Biathlon machen. Ah ja. Obwohl sie keine Lust hatte auf Schießen und das halt einfach Teil der Sache war, aber weiter, da sind halt die Preisgelder höher, da hat man Sponsoren, da gibt es grössere Vereine, grössere Veranstaltungen als bei Langlauf. Und deswegen war sie immer todtraurig am Gewehr und dann immer auf den Schienen und am Gewehr so. Ich hasse das. Muss ich einfach. Och ja, schon wieder alle fünf gekriegt und weiter geht's. Lauf, lauf, lauf, lauf, lauf, lauf. Bei mir wäre es genau umgekehrt. Ich glaube, bei mir auch. Ich würde mir so ein Jetski holen, so ein Ski-Jetski und dann halt wahnsinnig viele Strafpunkte kriegen. Und dann sagst du, Herr Will, Sie kriegen fünf Strafrunden. Ja, fahre ich den ganzen Tag mit dem Ding rum, ist mir egal, solange ich schießen darf. Und dann stehe ich da und... Aber Ironie des Schicksals, die Beat, gut, stimmt nicht, ich glaube, eine Beatlecene hat auch Gold gewonnen, jetzt bei den Olympischen Spielen, aber haben das Langlauf-Team der Frauen Silber geholt. Und viele Biathleten, Biathleten haben auch nichts geschissen bekommen.
Also, ja, vielleicht jetzt Langlauf kommt's.
Vielleicht wär's was. Da habe ich tatsächlich ganz kurz überlegt, Profisportler zu werden,
weil die war echt gut, meine Cousine, und die hatte dann auch so ein Sponsoring von Milka.
Und dafür hat sie ganz viel Milka-Schokolade bekommen.
Also da hat sie mir gezeigt, ich habe jetzt diese Tüte bekommen, wo ich mir auch dachte, holy crap, ich mache jetzt mehr Sport, um mehr Schokolade zu kriegen. Wenn ich von Milka gesponsert werde, habe ich richtig viel Schokolade. Das waren diese kleinen, kennst du diese kleinen Täflchen, die so Briefmarken gross waren. Briefmarken gross? Davon hatte die Hunderte, Tausend! Das fand ich schwierig, da muss man sehr viel dafür tun, das ist wie Pistazien zu essen. Ja, aber ich mag das. Ich finde das nicht schlecht. Ich finde das nicht schlecht. Und manchmal packe ich auch mehr schon aus, dann habe ich drei da so nackte Liegen und ich denke mir, ihr geht alle drauf heute noch. Aber weiss Milka, dass sie am eigenen Ast sägen, wenn sie ihre Sportler mit Milka versorgen? Ja, vielleicht in deren Perspektive ja nicht. Ich finde, die sägen am eigenen Ast. Wenn die den meinst, es ist so eine Art natürliches Balancing-System, dass die Sportler, die besonders gut sind, werden dadurch, dass sie von Fastfood-Ketten Milka und Coca-Cola gesponsert werden, werden sie wieder so runtergedrückt.
Um das Feld zusammenzuhalten.
Ja, Mäckle. Einfach hier kriegt es acht Stück Butter, die sponsern noch sowas auch.
Wohingegen die schlechten Sportler dann so von ween Blutkörperchen gesponsert werden. Hier, ist das. Ja, so läuft das. Finde ich nicht schlecht. Mal schauen, ich bin gespannt, wo uns die Profikarriere noch hinführt, ob da noch was geht. Erzähl uns doch unbedingt, wie es weitergeht mit diesen spannenden, irrespannenden Waldvideos. Auf jeden Fall, werde ich machen und ich werde weiterhin Lars Kritze schauen. Ich habe echt momentan viel auf dem Schreibtisch, also ich habe kaum noch Freizeit, diese Bahn Ruheabteilnummer, jetzt Lars Kritze, dann diese Waldnummer und dann will ich auch nochmal in die Mülltüten reingucken, also das ist mittlerweile echt ein Vollzeitjob für mich. Ihr könnt euch auf die nächsten Folgen freuen, die werden hochspannend. Content-Lawine. Also die Themen, die werden echt immer interessanter hier, das ist ruhig, crazy. Früher haben wir über Licht
gesprochen und auch jetzt
reden wir über Mülltüten.
Viele sagen, unsere Kritiker,
das ist ein Fingerzeigerichtung
Kritiker, die meinten uns gegen die Themen aus.
Nein. Nee, wir haben noch nicht mal angefangen.
Wir sind gerade bei der Mülltüte, wir sind noch nicht mal bei Müll.
Wir sind noch nicht bei Mülleimer.
Wir sind erst bei der Tüte, ganz außen.
Wir haben noch eine ganze Welt vor uns.
In diesem Sinne, macht es jut.
Macht's gut, bis nächste Woche.
Ciao.